.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU AND BEST
OF LUCK.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
SO THE QUESTION YOU HAVE TO
ASK WITH THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
, IF BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE SUCH A STRONG ROAD OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS PRACTICALLY
THE ENTIRE CAMPAIGN IS ABOUT
ABORTION AND JANUARY 6.
BECAUSE IT IS KIND OF
SPECTACULAR WITH THE CENTRAL
ISSUE OF INFLATION THAT IS
DRIVEN BY ENERGY POLICY AND IT
TAKES REAL POLITICAL
TALENT, GENIUS TO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT AN ENERGY POLICY IS
INCOHERENT SELF-DEFEATING AND
SHALLOW AS THE ONE.
>> JUST IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
DESPERATE TO BRING DOWN PRICES
AT THE PUMP BEFORE ELECTION
DAY THEY OFFER TO EASE
SANCTIONS AGAINST THE CORRUPT
BASKETS CASE REWORDING THE
REGIME AT THE EXACT MOMENT THE
BLAMING IT FOR THE RAGING
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE SAW THE FIST PUMP OF SHAME
THROWN BACK IN BIDEN'S FACE AS
THE SAUDI'S TEAMED UP WITH
RUSSIA TO CUT PROTECTIONS OF
INCREASING IT THAT BIDEN
BEGGED THEM TO DO AND THEN THE
RESERVES ARE NEARLY AT THE
LOWEST WITH WORRIES IT IS
GETTING TOO THIN TO PROPERLY
ADDRESS ANOTHER BIG GLOBAL
SUPPLY DISRUPTION
DEMONSTRATING THAT BIDEN
LOSING A RESERVES IS ONE OF
THE MOST IRRESPONSIBLE SCHEMES
FROM PRESIDENTIAL HISTORY.
ON TOP OF ALL THAT THEY PUSH
FOR THE AREA NUCLEAR DEAL TO
GET IRANIAN OIL BACK ON THE
MARKET INCLUDING THE MOBSTERS
WHO JUST SO KILLED FOR JOINING
THE PROTEST.
>> AND NOW LED BY THE BIDEN
REGIME AND THEN TO BE
EFFECTIVELY STANDING AGAINST
EVEN AFTER RELEASING THIS AD
AIMED AT DRUMMING UP SUPPORT
FROM WOMEN IN AMERICA.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE A CLUE OF
THE POWER OF WOMEN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO FIND OUT.
>> WHY WOULD SHE CRASH THE
POWER AND THEN THE VIRTUES
SIGNALING THAT CONTROL THE
PA